[Music]
all right the Democratic primary is off
to a pretty rocky start
as the two frontrunners Joe Biden creepy
Uncle Joe and Bernie Sanders are facing
a little bit of reckoning as questions
swirl now about the coveted Obama
endorsement New York Times reporting
that Obama had urged whoa crazy Uncle
Joe not to run in 2016
meanwhile senator Bernie Sanders is in
some hot water tonight new documents and
footage reviewed by Fox news.com reveal
that he has a history of praising
violent socialist revolutionaries and
policies such as forced land
redistribution like in Cuba there's
reaction much more the author of a
brand-new book just out today Sean
Hannity com amazon.com bookstores
everywhere it's called collusion that's
the that's not rip from the from the
day's headlines sometimes get lucky and
by the way if you're in New York or New
Jersey you're gonna be at Ridgewood New
Jersey at 6 o'clock tomorrow they sell
out Eastern I'm good to see how are you
I never see the video much it was
collusion it was now the New York Times
two and a half years of lying yeah
they're saying it looks like was
probably rushing disinformation now Bob
Woodruff it's gonna be wild if it turns
out that that entire dossier was a plant
by the Russians mr. speaker they never
verified it and they used it in for FISA
applications and it was a backdoor into
all of Trump campaign what if you knew
Trump was bad why would you verify it
because in fact it fit all of your
previous beliefs she's saying that with
a smile this that's an attempt remember
they think that the Washington posed a
coup d'etat Trump is right Trump's
language when he interviewed you or you
interviewed him I guess the other leader
was himself it's sort of a cherry street
but his comments which other news media
reacted to negatively as they should
because there is enemies this was an
attempted coup d'etat this was an effort
by a group of people to undermine the
choice of the American people because
they had arrogated to themselves that
they were morally superior and they
had the right to deny us the
constitutional system that's what it was
here's I look at it in three different
phases phase 1 Hilary's investigation we
know was rigged right struck and Paige
are laughing about it the Attorney
General it's a matter it's not a an
investigation and then the tarmac and
then look they they're saying oh they're
all Democrats this is the fix is in
right they're saying that now the next
phase of it is okay then the attempt to
spy on a campaign to rig an election
with their favorite candidate that they
got off the hook then the aftermath of
which is to then undermine a duly
elected president and bludgeon him with
those Russian lies I think that's
exactly right and I think the challenge
to the President and to Attorney General
Boris to have the nerve to calmly and
methodically get everything out in the
open let the American people see how
sick the system had gotten we know that
people are going to have to be held
accountable okay you can't rig an
investigation for your favored candidate
you can't present to a FISA Court one
candidates bought and paid for Russian
dossier not verified not told the court
that Hillary paid for it they knew it
they didn't tell the FISA Court you know
as a report out I think today or
yesterday that 53 percent of American
people think corruption is a major
problem well they're right this is all a
corrupt behavior by a power structure
part of the bureaucratic part of it news
media part of it politicians and
lobbyists put a power structure that
decided it could protect its favorite it
could destroy the person a disliked and
it could do all of it outside the law in
a way that is clearly a total violation
you are a great historian how did this
happen in America the system had grown
steadily and steadily more corrupt do
you thats the biggest burden joe biden
will carry is part of the corrupt system
he's got two answers either I was in the
room and knew it or nobody would ever
tell me no the one answer
was in the room I think he was in the
room I think he knew it and I think the
fact is the Joe Biden and Barack Obama
consciously sought to lie to the
American people and to undermine the
results of an election so you see this
this cast the characters many of which
are even supporting the new Green Deal
eliminate the combustion engine oil and
gas cows it's not well I I'm sorry I
dumped me on my proposed lately me it's
not Christmas and they've rushed up to
you in a box and said geez don't tell
anybody our secret but that's what he
candidates are saying they support this
that's because nobody yet has gone to
their districts and said let me explain
how really stupid this is well okay but
you got frankly look at a hundred
Democrats and in the Senate in the house
that liked it
yeah presidential candidates it like it
right who do you think it's good to
question who's gonna win this primary
who do you think do you think it's Biden
do you think it's Sanders do you think
it's somebody else well I think I am
never consider I think it's a Buddha
judge yeah it's Buddha judge I'm trying
I'm trying I think he is the best chance
because he's the most like Jimmy Carter
that is he's a blank slate everybody can
pretend they like him without ever
knowing what he really stands for any of
he's clever he'll always be like number
three or number four until they until
they get to the vote okay who do you
think would be the toughest for
president Trump look we always vote
peace and prosperity we've never had a
better economy are you better off than
you were four years ago I know how much
the president likes you and so I'm a
little cautious to say this because he
would probably see this oh boy
no the biggest challenger to Donald
Trump's reelection is Donald Trump why
because with a little bit of discipline
and a little bit of focus he would
become unbeatable have you there's never
been and you're the greatest story you
can correct me if I'm wrong somebody
that is this much of a disrupter
iconic West I think his greatest gift is
keeping his word he fights to everything
he said he would do he's doing look I
keep telling people Biden wants to run
is mr. mr. night likable Pleasant guy
yeah Trump has done all my run as mr.
tough guy who gets things done the
country's got to decide in a real world
do you want this nice Pleasant doofus
who's not going to anything done what do
you want this tough guy who has
weaknesses but by god he gets things
done what about the Abidin Obama record
13 million more Americans on food stamps
8 million more poverty you've heard me
say that a lot I doubt if we'll get to
that with Biden because he's gonna fall
apart first so you think it's food a
judge if you had to guess today about
yesterday's food Oh judge now you can
play this later on this smaller play
well okay
we might do that just for fun well
collusion ripped up right out of the
headlines if you're in New Jersey
bookend 6 p.m. tomorrow you know it
cracks me up this this is a novel but
it's real life that's right
mr. speaker always good to see you
thanks so much for meeting with us